[Aplausos]
você pode se lembrar onde você aprendeu
sobre disciplina ou ainda onde aplica
peço que considerem por pelo menos um
instante o fato de serem pessoas
disciplinadas a disciplina ela pode ser
baseada na capacidade que você tem em
colocar as suas condutas e os seus
valores para compartilhar com o outro
ela pode ser vista de diversas formas
porém eu quero chamar a atenção pra
interdisciplinaridade e inter indica
movimento tanto entre quanto dentro das
disciplinas é como se houvesse uma
relação dinâmica entre os saberes no
trabalho interdisciplinar não se ensina
nem se aprende
você vive você exerce
eu sei sobre química e você sabe sobre
matemática mas podemos compartilhar os
nossos saberes
eu sou uma engenheira que você sabe
sobre o meio ambiente
será que eu eu querer construir uma
ponte
eu tenho que levar em consideração a
quantidade de árvores que eu vou
desmatar
será que eu tenho que levar em
consideração se poderia ter uma
população nesse espaço será se eu tenho
que levar em consideração que poderia
ter uma enchente daqui dez anos se eu
vou construir uma ponte neste espaço
se nós compartilhamos os nossos saberes
se nós juntarmos duas áreas que a gente
acha que não tem nada que poderia juntar
a nós podemos fazer um trabalho
interdisciplinar a complexidade da
interdisciplinaridade se faz de grande
importância
os seus envolvidos eles precisam ter
noção
são as suas capacidades de quais são as
suas habilidades para assim conseguir
compartilhar os saberes bem logo no
início eu pedi pra vocês considerarem o
fato de serem pessoas disciplinadas
mas agora eu quero instigá los quando na
vida você atuou de forma
interdisciplinar
quando é que você juntou o seu melhor
com o outro quando que esse
compartilhamento quando o que você viu
que essa ação que você fez com o outro
você viu que você teve um envolvimento e
não foi apenas juntar duas áreas mas
você viu que você se envolveu na estação
assim como eu pedir a vocês eu também
parei pra pensar onde eu aprendi sobre
disciplina e foi aí que me lembrei da
pessoa que deu todo sentido à minha vida
eu fui criada pela minha avó minha voz
não teve oportunidade de estudar eu não
sei nem se a oportunidade porque ela
dizia que o seu pai não a deixava
estudar porque senão a linha fazer
cartinha para o namorado
mas enfim ela casou com meu avô
ela teve os seus filhos e ela não
conseguiu transferir esse sonho dos seus
filhos mas a minha avó ela viu em mim a
oportunidade de continuar sonhando
ela viu em mim a oportunidade de colocar
o seu sonho em prática
então eu fui para a escola enfrentei
dificuldades que toda criança em
desenvolvimento enfrenta mas a minha avó
me ensinou que uma disciplina eu poderia
vencer todas essas dificuldades
ela ainda dizia assim mesmo com apenas a
sua sabedoria popular
mesmo sem o ensino superior ela dizia
família faça exercício físico é uma das
formas de você ter disciplina faz alguma
atividade que esteja relacionada faça
algum exercício físico ela nem sabia mas
que eram os benefícios do exercício
físico mas ela imaginava que seria uma
forma de ter disciplina e hoje eu sei
que essa
somente por isso que eu escolhi a
educação física ser humano me atrai
o cuidado o acolhimento à humanização
que o profissional de educação física
traz em sua prática profissional e então
eu imaginava que entrar na universidade
seria o mais difícil até eu entrar e
perceber que permanecer e ser uma das
minhas lutas diárias
os meus colegas eles pareciam conquistar
as notas sem grandes esforços e
constantemente ouvir a família o que
você entendeu isso é tão simples é tão
fácil mas isso não me entristecia anmp
fazia perceber que essas limitações que
eu poderia ter uma disciplina eu poderia
vencer esses obstáculos
realmente as minhas notas não eram boas
mas o fato da minha vó ter me ensinado
sobre disciplina me fez aprender a ter
fé e concentrar na minha própria
história
durante esse tempo eu avaliei os meus
objetivos
eu analisei os meus resultados superei
os meus obstáculos e computei vitórias e
são sobre essas vitórias que eu também
quero compartilhar com vocês hoje o
trabalho nasce o nasf é o núcleo de
apoio à saúde da família
nós somos uma equipe interdisciplinar
que damos apoio a uma equipe que é
composta por médico enfermeiro e agentes
comunitários de saúde
a minha equipe é composta por eu que sou
profissional de educação física por duas
fisioterapeutas por um fonoaudiólogo por
uma nutricionista uma psicóloga uma
assistente social e também uma terapeuta
ocupacional
trata se de um serviço interdisciplinar
com sentido de como objetivo de apoiar e
ampliar o cuidado fazendo com que o
sujeito tem a qualidade de vida fazendo
com que o sujeito tem autonomia e com
que ele seja protagonista da sua
própria história e minha atuação
profissional
ela não está relacionado somente a
prática do exercício físico
eu me permito por conta do meu trabalho
interdisciplinar atender diversas
demandas
eu enquanto profissional de educação
física
eu posso atender uma criança que tem
dificuldade de fala porque eu troquei
saberes com meu colega eu realizei
atendimentos com ele eu fiz grupos com
ele que me permite essa atuação atender
uma criança com dificuldade de fala
não me faz fonoaudióloga me faz uma
profissional que vai ter uma atuação
interdisciplinar
hoje eu trabalho com uma população de
grande vulnerabilidade social e não
apenas social mas também uma
vulnerabilidade cultural
mas é lá que eu sei que eu tenho que ter
um compromisso com a minha verdade com
que eu aprendi lá na infância ainda com
a minha avó que foi moldado na
universidade
então eu quero trazer um relato de uma
paciente para poder elucidar um pouco do
que eu tenho falado para vocês a
respeito da interdisciplinaridade e para
isso eu vou dar o nome dessa paciente de
dona maria a dona maria tem 60 anos
ela mora em sua casa com duas filhas ela
não trabalha na casa da dona maria
estava sempre fechada sempre escura
ela costumava receber ninguém em sua
casa e quando haveria necessidade de
receber a dona maria abria apenas uma
fresta da porta
ela passou então em atendimento com
médico e ela foi diagnosticada com
depressão e síndrome do pânico
o que era esperado após o nascimento e
após a discussão com laço que era
esperado é que dona maria ela fosse
atendida pela psicóloga mas realizamos o
atendimento eu ea fisioterapeuta
nós acolhemos a dona maria quando ela
chegou em nosso consultório nós podemos
perceber o quanto a dona maria estava
entristecida o quanto o seu estado de
humor era depressivo ela não conseguia
nem se comunicar e com muita dificuldade
dona maria nos contou que ela roubou a
sua bolsa três dias antes do atendimento
e ela ensaiava o ir até a porta da sua
casa para que ela conseguisse sair e ela
conseguisse chegar nesse atendimento
vendo os parâmetros psicológicos
biológicos e culturais da dona maria
nós realizamos então um projeto
terapêutico de cuidado juntamente com
ela nesse projeto terapêutico de cuidado
dona maria ela foi convidada a fazer
parte de um grupo de exercício físico e
ela foi fazer parte desse grupo
nesse grupo mas realizamos atividades de
alongamento e flexibilidade de força
dança e os benefícios que a dona maria
teve nesse grupo foi para além dos
benefícios do exercício físico pode
trazer a dona maria ela ganhou qualidade
de vida
ela ganhou saúde a dona maria ganhou
amigos
antes ela não saía de casa o nariz hoje
ela já não pára mais em casa ela já não
é mais dependente da sua família como
ela era antes e ela fala com muita
alegria a quantidade de medicamento que
ela reduziu após realizar o projeto
terapêutico de cuidado que ela também
acreditou que poderia ser possível ela
fazer a dona maria recentemente fez uma
tatuagem como forma de comemoração
veja só e ela ainda a gente achou que
chegou na tatuagem está ok mas não ela
participou de um concurso e ela ganhou o
miss terceira idade do bairro em que ela
mora
veja bem quando eu trago caso da dona
maria pra vocês para elucidar o que eu
acredito de interdisciplinaridade é
porque acredito que o processo
saúde-doença ele tem que ser traduzido
nesta interrelação e eu defendo nasce
como uma proposta de cuidado de grande
intervenção na saúde pública
eu acredito que a forma interdisciplinar
de trabalho ela pode ser vista não
somente no nasf mas que em diversas
áreas a gente pode trabalhar de forma
interdisciplinar e eu convido vocês a
pensar
no brasil mais junto
será que você como a sua profissão como
seu saber com o seu conhecimento com as
suas capacidades você sabe quais são as
suas capacidades
você sabe quais são as suas habilidades
será que você consegue compartilhar com
o outro o que você tem de melhor
será que você consegue absorver do outro
e trabalhar de forma interdisciplinar
ainda hoje ao encontrar um outro
profissional e pergunte a ele o que eu
posso aprender com você e vá além e
coloque em prática o que você aprendeu
com seu colega se a
interdisciplinaridade a reciprocidade a
encontro
muito obrigada
[Música]
acho que está muito obrigado
[Aplausos]